claude blanchemaison bonjour un jour de
vous retrouver dans la matinale de rtl
france alors dans quelle mesure les
résultats ces municipales marc telle une
défiance à l'égard de la ncg ce sont
d'abord des élections municipales ce ne
sont pas des élections législatives
générales et lors des dernières
municipales la une c'est avait déjà
marqué une petite baisse dansé dansé
dansé score puisqu'elles étaient
légèrement au-dessus de 50% donc là on
n'a pas encore les résultats définitifs
mais il est probable que ce sera un
petit peu en dessous de 50% lors des
dernières élections elle avait perdu les
grandes villes comme johannesburg
qu'elle avait retrouvé un peu plus tard
en raison d'alliances eu diverses et
variées elle avait aussi perdu le cap et
donc on constate que dans les grandes
villes il y à un mécontentement dans les
grandes villes ça veut dire aussi dans
les townships c'est à dire les anciennes
zones où habitait à l'époque de
l'apartheid la population noire est
effectivement il ya un grand
mécontentement parce que
il ya comme vous l'avez dit beaucoup de
chômage entre un tiers et 40 % de la
population active c'est beaucoup il ya
des services publics qui fonctionnent
pas bien notamment dans les townships
avec des coupures d'électricité très
importante à soweto township de
johannesbourg emblématique et c'est
d'ailleurs là où à voter cyril ramaphosa
parce que c'est là où il a vécu il a été
élevé et effectivement cette corruption
dont on a accusé la haine s'est à
plusieurs reprises et notamment le
précédent président qui est actuellement
soumis à des accusations jugées et même
d'ailleurs condamné pour injure à
magistrat et porte un bracelet
électronique a été libéré pour des
raisons médicales mais effectivement la
rca a perdu son aura deux parties qui
avaient eu raison de l'apartheid et
d'autres parties commencent à émerger
mais je ne crois pas que là il s'est
perdu la main pour autant qu'elles
pourraient être les réactions du présent
l'afrique du sud cyril ramaphosa
il a fait de la lutte contre la
corruption son cheval de bataille depuis
le depuis le début et cyril ramaphosa
est un homme d'action on l'a connue
autrefois comme leader syndical du
syndicat cosatu qu'était le syndicat des
mineurs le principal syndicat de la
population noire et je pense qu'il veut
entreprendre en effet c'est très
difficile une réforme de la lc et qu'il
se rend compte aussi que dans les villes
et dans les townships comme je les dis
il faut que le service public revienne
soit efficace qu'il y ait des
fournitures d'eau d'électricité
de également
une couverture sanitaire qui soit
convenable à côté d'un certain nombre de
bureaux l'élection on avait d'ailleurs
mis des épaules de vaccination parce que
le taux le taux de vaccination est
encore très faible en afrique du sud et
la mortalité est importante c'est pas
très étonnant d'ailleurs compte tenu de
la façon dont vivent les mineurs qui
sont logés dans des hostel les uns sur
les autres avec une promiscuité qui
favorise bien entendu la contagion donc
je pense que ramaphosa est probablement
bien placé pour faire cette réforme et
que peut-être que ce coup de semonce des
mets des municipales ben finalement lui
rendre service à lui à l'intérieur de la
haine c'est alors clos d'ici la
prochaine présidentielle en 2024 la
stabilité du pays est elle menacée
l'échiquier politique peut-il être
renversé alors le principal parti
d'opposition c'est l'alliance
démocratique qui a un défaut c'est que
elle est née à l'époque de l'apartheid
et à la une une coloration du parti des
blancs ce qui était le cas à l'origine
ce qui n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
donc elle a fait aux dernières élections
environ 15 15 à 20% elle est donc très
très loin de pouvoir atteindre la main
de la majorité et encore une fois elle
doit démontrer quel est le parti de la
nation arc en ciel comme disait le
premier président de l'afrique du sud de
l'afrique du sud après l'apartheid c'est
à dire de tous les sud africains les
noirs les blancs les métis et les
indiens puisqu'à l'époque il y avait
cette distinction formel entre les
différentes catégories de la population
alors est ce que l'alliance démocratique
sera capable de réaliser cette mutation
peut-être mais ça prendra beaucoup de
temps il ya d'autres partis qui sont des
petits partis généralement créé par des
dissidents de l'alliance démocratique
des partis centristes libéraux qui sont
très très loin d'atteindre les 5 % des
voix donc il y aura une évolution est
naturellement la une c'est doit se dire
que avait le temps dans la dans la durée
il faudra probablement se faire à l'idée
d'une alternance
merci beaucoup claude pour toutes ces
précisions on aura les résultats
vraisemblablement je dise merci claude